[Music]  bridgette i'm old  and i seem like i can't remember nothing  no more  i try to say what day it is  ain't got a clue  hey  so you want me to take you to that  special doctor  one of them i can help you remember  things  [Music]  you ready to come in later no it's just  you and me but reggie do you want to go  see this doctor so  we developed a treatment  mr gray will remember everything that he  has ever known but the treatment will  only work once is that what you want  i got a lot of things to do  and i need my memory  to do it  gray  how you feeling never better that's fat  i can see it all  so clear now  my man's whole lifetime spinning around  in there  my cordo stole something  treasure  i'ma find it  peppa grey i'm worried about you the  rate the decline was accelerating i mean  in my mind gonna be worse than it was  the folks  but i got to finish this  you got to let the river take its course  and the river know right where it's  going  [Music]  [Music]  foreign